hi I'm dr. see me as men and from 2011
to 2013 I was an officer in the epidemic
intelligence service so today I'm gonna
match the time line of contagion with
the timeline of kovat 19:00 contagion
starts on day 2 and we see Gwyneth
Paltrow's character is sick and then a
montage of other six civilians or
demonstrating symptoms within one day of
transmission everyone we see who gets
sick with this has a cough a fever
seizures and then dies within three to
four days the virus in contagion is
fictional is called mev one but it is a
hybrid of two real-life infections
influenza and NEPA NEPA is a real-life
virus a very serious one that can cause
fever shortness of breath swelling of
the brain coma and seizures the illness
caused by M eveyone is very different to
covet nineteen where people get sick
over the course of two to fourteen days
and unlike the fictional virus in
contagion death from Co vid 19 isn't
typically so sudden so in this scene
we're looking at day five which is the
day that the World Health Organization
is notified of the outbreak what we are
hearing from Beijing is that the
outbreak is contained to the
chrysanthemum complex in Hong Kong we're
also looking at symbols from London to
clusters here's the first time that they
used the word cluster and that can refer
to cases that are literally clustered
together in time and place we still
don't know who was the first person to
become infected with SARS Kobe - and
when that was but we do know that
Chinese officials alerted the World
Health Organization on December 31st of
2019 then it would be day 21 when the
United States identified its first cases
on day six and contagion the CDC learns
of a cluster of cases an elementary
school in Minnesota there's a cluster in
an elementary school and we start
hearing here some very familiar language
we're isolating the second and
quarantining those who we believe we're
exposed and that's exactly what happened
here in the US people who had symptoms
were isolated from others and those who
were exposed to those who had symptoms
were then quarantined the average person
touches their face two or three thousand
times a day two or three thousand times
a day so in this scene we have Kate
Winslet playing an officer in the
epidemic intelligence service the job
that I used to have and she's talking to
health officials at the Minnesota
Department of Health I think we have to
believe this is respiratory maybe four
mites - what's that fomites this is
stuff they would already know especially
when you're looking at the fact that
it's the Minnesota Department of Health
which is known to be one of the best
departments of health in the country it
refers to transmission from surfaces
fomites are inanimate objects and
surfaces things I could door handle or
lights where do those things become full
night one of the things that's very
silly to me about contagion is that Kate
Winslet is sent on her own to
investigate this epidemic in real life
with something of this magnitude with a
novel infection you'd be sent with a
team not alone epidemic investigations
are all about teamwork for every person
who gets sick how many other people are
they likely to infect we call that
number we are not her description of our
law is accurate R stands for the
reproductive rate of the virus R naught
is the basic reproductive number of an
infection which means the average a
number of people one infected person
will go on to infect in a susceptible
population once it gets to below one
meaning that one infected person is on
average infecting fewer than one people
that's when you see an epidemic stop
because you're breaking the chain of
transmission now R naught of Tsarskoe V
two is thought to be somewhere between
1.5 and 3.5
we did Pilates together I called her
after she got back I never heard from
her so you had no contact with her in
this scene the epidemic intelligence
service officer is doing what we call
contact tracing with contact tracing you
first talk to the person who is sick and
then you find out when were they
contagious did she go to the class
I didn't fear them then you follow up on
that long list of people there anyone
else who might have had contact with her
one thing that I do find strange about
the current coab in 19 pandemic is here
in the states contact tracing got
shifted to the backburner
almost as if officials were saying
there's too much spread and now it's too
difficult to do contact tracing and
compare that to South Korea where
there's been very thorough contact
tracing for every single person who's
shown symptoms in this scene the
researchers are talking about sequencing
the virus in the movie we've sequence
the virus and determined its origin and
we've modeled the way it enters the
cells of the lung in the brain and
sequencing is where you analyze the
genetic material inside the virus the
virus contains both bad and pig
sequences here they're analyzing the
protein structure of the virus Lou is
virus and the gold is human and the red
is the viral attachment protein and the
green as its receptor in the human cells
this kind of molecular structure in
rendering is accurate research has a
look at 3d models like this to determine
how a virus invades human cells so we
have a novel virus with a mortality rate
in the low 20s no treatment protocol and
no vaccine at this time it is accurate
to say there are novel characteristics
because that's what you say when you're
dealing with a very new virus one which
you haven't seen anything quite like it
before
sequencing a virus is really important
so that you can develop a test for it
the test that we typically use is called
PCR which means polymerase chain
reaction and the way it works is you
take a sample from somebody's nose for
example and then you are putting it
through this system that amplifies the
genetic material inside the virus and
they did this really quickly within ten
days in the movie which is pretty close
what we saw in real life with SARS Co v2
where Chinese scientists had sequenced
the genome by January 7th and that's
about day 8 of our timeline and this
timeline actually matches up pretty well
with the movie
he tried antibodies and immunological
knockout lines like we did it but the
key was a fetal bat cell line from which
along this scene is really accurate
because if you can't grow the virus
inside a laboratory then you're not able
to study it propagate it and really
understand what it looks like how it
behaves and how you might treat it but
the key was a fetal bad cell line from
too long we didn't have it and the
scientist says they were able to
successfully grow the virus inside cells
that came from bat lungs in a case of
Tsarskoe v2 it was also successfully
propagated early on in a lab using a
different kind of cell though it used
kidney cells that came from a specific
kind of monkey this is a really
important step in terms of developing
treatments and vaccines for a new virus
so here's a really great question that
one of the characters asks if I'm immune
can't you use my blood to cure this this
is something we actually do in medicine
it's a technique that dates back to the
Victorian times where say somebody
survived an infection with a virus you
can take their blood separate the
antibodies out of it those are the
proteins that helped them fight off the
infection and give those antibodies to
others to help them it's often a stopgap
measure that's used during epidemics
like with the Ebola epidemic of 2014 we
didn't have any specific treatments we
didn't have a vaccine so while all of
that stuff was being developed we took
blood from Ebola survivors and use that
blood to treat and protect others for
SARS Kobe Chu there are currently
studies looking into antibody treatments
where blood transfers could help sick
people fight off the virus on day 13 in
contagion they report more than 3000
cases in the suburbs of Minneapolis
3,000 cases have been confirmed in the
western suburbs in our timeline on March
26 Washington state officials announced
more than 3,200 cases in the state and
that would be day 65 since the first
case in the US was reported again it
just shows how different the diseases in
the movie compared to code 19
around day 13 dr. Mia sets up a
temporary hospital in a public space I
want 25 rolls for 10 beds apiece
the most febrile cases of this and they
say that it needs to be operational
within 24 to 48 hours we need to be
operational within the next 24 to 48
hours this scene actually does match up
with what we saw happen in New York City
which quickly became the American
epicenter of the pandemic in March New
York Governor Cuomo announced that the
Javits Center would be converted into an
emergency hospital and the Army Corps of
Engineers went in and converted that
space into a 2,000 bed makeshift
hospital in real life though it took
over a week to set that up not the 48
hours that we see in the movie we call
these kinds of hospitals mobile field
hospitals and many states and countries
will have plans in place to make those
appear quickly in the case of an
emergency
in this scene CDC scientists are
tracking down the index patients or any
closer to an index patient could be your
Beth Emhoff or the guy on the bus and
Japan someone else had crawled off the
grid and they find out that it's Queen
of Paltrow's character there and Hough
is the index patient index patient is
the term that you may hear used
interchangeably with the term
when I was in the epidemic intelligence
service I was taught that the index case
is the first case that you identify that
patient zero is the true first case in
the epidemic in this scene there's a
health investigator watching video
footage of who they think is their index
case in a casino
okay it's transmission so we just need
to know which direction with Tsarskoe v2
the investigation is still ongoing and
we don't know who the first human cases
were or where and how they became
infected there was a lot of
finger-pointing early on at a particular
seafood market in Wuhan but some of the
genetic analysis and the epidemiologic
analysis shows that actually there were
people infected earlier on who may have
had no contact with that particular
market similarly to the casino in
contagion there have been outbreaks of
kovat 19 traced back to densely
populated areas and places like a church
in South Korea so I want to call out
something from a movie that is pure
Hollywood Kate Winslet's character
playing the role of the officer in the
epidemic intelligence service dies from
the very virus that she is investigating
and as far as I know this has never
happened in the 69 year history of the
epidemic intelligence service in this
scene the media starts talking about a
drug a quarter ripe of ayran the drug
River Baron has been shown to be
effective against this virus this is a
real-life medication that fights viruses
and it's been around for a really long
time and similarly with the code 19
timeline the President of the US did
bring up an existing old-school medicine
and asked if that would work against the
new corona virus so the drug that he
mentioned was hydroxychloroquine and
chloroquine which are old-school malaria
drugs also use nowadays
to treat lupus and some types of
arthritis there is little evidence but
hydroxychloroquine is a reliable
treatment a coded nineteen there are
therapies we know are effective right
now like forsythia Jude Law plays this
really sleazy character who's saying
that they cured themselves using a kind
of homeopathic treatment and then trying
to sell this to others and profit from
it
this is forsythia from here tomorrow
you'll note works I'm not the first
person to make money off the fact that
our immune system is a work in progress
this is really common during epidemics
and pandemics with covered 19 we've seen
internet personalities and people like
Alex Jones no surprise peddling fake
cures and trying to profit off the
crisis
where did you come from
in this scene CDC scientists find out
that by day 21 the virus has mutated its
mutated a phylogenetic analysis is
basically like creating a family tree
for a pathogen to figure out where it
originated from and how it evolved the
Durban cluster is highly divergent what
they're talking about there is the virus
has mutated so much so it looks very
different to the original strains we
have a new are Nautilus it's not -
anymore and then we hear that the Arnor
has changed it's not - anymore and that
can definitely happen during the course
of an epidemic that are nor can increase
and decrease ideally it decreases
because of all the interventions you're
putting into place like physical
distancing health education development
of a vaccine those things to drive they
are not down we tried using dead virus
combined with several regiments to boost
immune response and no protective
antibodies lighter dead monkeys so here
the researchers are failing in their
attempts to produce protective
antibodies to the virus a live
attenuated virus is a virus that's still
alive but one that you've tweaked so it
can't be as potent combined with several
edge of an adjuvant had defense the
chemicals that we add into vaccines to
stimulate your immune system so that the
vaccine works at this point with
Tsarskoe v2 it's way too early in the
vaccine trials to say by the any of
those experimental vaccines actually
work and produce protective antibodies
in people
by day 26 the world is staying at home
this scene just shows a bunch of places
that have emptied out which kind of
feels a bit overly familiar with what
we're going through right now as the
death toll in the United States is now
believed to have reached 2.5 million the
President issued a statement today from
an undisclosed location by day 29 in the
contagion timeline mev 1 has killed 2.5
million people in the United States but
in real life by day 29 of the cogut 19
pandemic there hadn't been any reported
deaths from the virus in the US and the
current projection is that the virus
could kill between a hundred thousand to
two hundred and forty thousand Americans
some early models suggested that kovat
19 could kill more than two million
Americans in a year if no measures were
taken to stop the spread of the disease
if we even had a viable vaccine right
now we would still have to do human
trials and that would take weeks so the
movie here portrays quite well I think
the disconnect between scientists and
the government then we would have to get
clearance and approval to figure out
manufacturing and distribution that
would take months
you see scientists working tirelessly to
develop a vaccine while government
officials just don't understand that it
takes a really long time to develop new
vaccines homeland security wants to know
if we could put a vaccination in the
water supply like fluoride cure everyone
all at once I'm going home now Ellen and
I have never heard of a vaccine being
put in a water supply we are seeing that
with this emergency of CO vid 19 that
with some experimental vaccines that
whole testing in animal stage is being
skipped and we're going straight to
phase 1 trials in humans
[Music]
in terms of a researcher acting as a
human test subject for a vaccine that
could happen it's pretty unusual though
in the movie the FDA fast tracks the
approval of the new vaccine the Food and
Drug Administration is accelerating
approval of the MeV one vaccine
currently in production at five secret
locations in the US and Europe this can
definitely happen in real life both with
a new vaccine or with new treatments if
the fda believes as a real need to it
can fast-track approval in the movie and
this is very Hollywood the timeline
jumps from day 29 when the researcher is
acting as a test subject today 131 when
magically this new vaccine is being
distributed to many people and I think
this creates a lot of force expectations
and false hope around the development of
a coded 19 vaccine there are ones being
developed now even some that have been
tested in humans but it's still too
early to say when a vaccine would be
available I love how they end the movie
I think to me it's the most prescient
part showing the transmission of this
new virus from a bat to a pig and then
to humans
this is probably really close to how
we're thinking about the transmission of
Tsarskoe v2 probably from bats to some
intermediate animal maybe a Pangolin and
then from that animal to humans and then
of course from one human to another
until it's spread around the world in
the end there's a lot of truth I think
in the contagion movie in terms of how a
pandemic might play out across the world
and in the US but as you can see from
watching this video there's a fair
amount of Hollywood liberties taken as
well I think some of the things that the
movie did not predict were the lack of
personal protective equipment available
in developed nations like the US and the
UK and of course the movie like so many
focuses entirely on the United States
doesn't give us a really good grasp of
how the pandemic plays out in different
parts of the world so did I miss any
scenes that you're confused about or do
you have any questions for me about what
it was like doing that job if so please
leave your questions here in the
comments section or reach me on social
media